[Music]
mmm
please
[Music]
boys
[Music]
back to the best business show i'm i
apologize for everything that's gonna
happen today we have peter schiff here
in the studio we've got joe and john as
well uh peter mccormick is on his way
he's stuck in traffic but he'll be here
shortly uh as you can imagine we're
gonna have a lot of fun today before we
get into today's show we've got a ton of
different things to cover the first
thing that we're gonna cover is so far
as a sponsor that means you go to
sofi.com there's no other sponsor in the
world that's going to bring together
peter schiff peter mccormick on the same
show and have them talk about how great
i mean bitcoin is and
we're going to have a lot of fun today
so sofi.com make sure you go there get a
account if you put two thousand dollars
in the investment account you'll join
the diamond hands club once you join the
diamond hands club
you get to come with us every other week
and join the diamond hand clubs meetings
we bring all kinds of different experts
you can ask some questions talk to us et
cetera make sure you go to software.com
open up an account
second of all if you want any of the
merchandise we got tons and tons of
merchandise all of the great hats that
peter is going to take home with him
bitcoin hundred k hats et cetera right
there are at thebestbusinessshow.com you
want to put one on for us they start the
show we don't accept gold
i said you got to cross off at least one
zero
[Laughter]
so we're gonna have some fun obviously
uh and
you at home all you gotta do is you just
hit the like button on the video and uh
we'll be off to the races um i don't
really have much else to do let's just
start what are you doing in miami well
what's everybody doing in miami
well other people are living here yeah
yeah all right that's why have you seen
have you bought any art yet no i said no
one will take my gold bars for the heart
i'm lugging him around you're getting
heavy
no i'm here i want to buy some nfts
really
of course not
do you really know let's have some
bitcoin art i brought it with me yeah
yeah it's right it's right here in fact
i put it it's all over the table
[Laughter]
all right that's like real art except it
you can't see it you can't touch it it
has no actual value no real
i have a utility question
do you own any bitcoin for real no well
i own some i just can't get at it why
well i guess i don't have my password
you said you realize that sounds right
but i don't know yes but i don't even
have a full bitcoin there it's only like
a third of a bitcoin okay so the good
thing you didn't send me something
that's 100.
20 000. so it's 20 000 for the bitcoin
yeah but you know that's the wallet you
were supposed to send me 100 worth of
bitcoin to you never did which is just
as well because you know it's lost okay
what would it take to get you to buy
some bitcoin
well why would i buy bitcoin though no
no you didn't answer the question what
would it take to get you to buy some
bitcoin
well i i guess how far would gold
gave me some money under the with the
condition that i had to use it to buy
bitcoin i guess i'd have to buy bitcoin
because i'm an honorable person so if it
was your money i guess i would buy it i
don't want to buy with my own money if
and when bitcoin passes gold's market
capital you buy some
well
a i don't think it's ever gonna pass
gold's market cap but you know that's a
good
starting point for a conversation
because everybody always wants to look
at the market cap of gold and just
assume that bitcoin is going to take
that market cap but
you know a good chunk of that market cap
probably half of it has to do with
gold's use and jewelry no wrong wrong
wrong yes it is seven percent no it's
not you want a bag
you want a bet what percent what percent
of gold's market cap is held by
investors
my guess my guess is uh a pretty big
percentage no it's about 20
you know so bitcoin already almost has
that market cap right because it can't
replace gold in industry it can't
replace gold in jewelry gold gold market
cap is about 13 trillion okay so
according to this hold on according to
this distribution of gold demand
worldwide bisector in 2020 this is uh
i'm talking about the actual hold on it
says jewelry is 36
investment is 46. central bank is eight
and technology is eight percent yeah but
i keep talking about that but the market
cap includes all the gold that's above
ground okay right that includes you know
the gold in everybody's jewelry
there's a lot of gold that's in that's
held in jewelry that's a good chunk of
the market cap so bitcoin can't take
that market cap
you you you can't make any jewelry out
of bitcoin i mean i think that bitcoin's
market cap is already close to gold when
it comes to individual
private ownership for investment
purposes i'm not counting central banks
so how much how much do you think is
investment demand for gold
50
no i think about 20
of the the above ground goal that's
right part of the market it'll be like
two trillion yeah two two yeah two two
and a half trillion and that's kind of
close to the market cap for bitcoin
already well that would be bitcoin would
have to double to get there no no but if
you take it points out bitcoins at one
trillion dollars right all right but if
you take all the cryptos yeah ether and
all the rest of the crap but those
aren't trying to compete well well sure
they are with gold no with bitcoin they
fail they're not they're trying to do
other things no they're not yeah they're
competing with bitcoin for people who
want to gamble on crypto tokens do you
think that most people are buying
bitcoin because they're trying to gamble
of course they're buying bitcoin because
they think it's going to a hundred
thousand or they think it's going to a
million that's why they're buying it but
how much of your portfolio is in stocks
like fifty percent well my portfolio
well my stock portfolio is all stocks
but like your financial portfolio what
percentages like just all equities in
general
well i mean if you exclude
real estate that i own yeah yeah and
private businesses yeah you look at like
how my you know like liquid portfolio
yeah i'm mostly in stocks okay vast
majority of what i have and so when you
buy them in stocks when you buy it
equity you're buying it because you
think that it's going to go up in value
against the dollar
no
mostly i'm buying companies that i think
are undervalued they pay good dividends
to me
i want to get out of paper i don't want
to own
bonds because i think bonds are going to
lose value you sold them all well i
didn't really sell my bonds because i
never really owned any i mean i had i
had some
uh foreign bonds
but i'm almost all in
non-us equities and a lot of those
equities
are
mining companies and those are the that
part of my portfolio has not been
performing well um gold stocks have
really gotten hit
all right i want to give i'm going to
give you some softballs i'm going to let
you
do what you do best ready first softball
they say inflation's 6.2 percent they've
been saying that it's transitory we now
have the retirement of the word
transitory like literally they should
have held an award ceremony put it in
the hall of fame it's retired yeah what
do you think about them not wanting to
use the word transitory anymore does
that mean that it's permanent or does
that mean that they just don't want to
talk about it anymore well i think
they're tired of trying to obfuscate as
to what they meant i mean i think
initially
when they said transitory they meant
transitory but then when it turned out
not to be transitory they had to kind of
redefine the word
and kind of you know to try to save face
but at this point they've they've
twisted it into such a pretzel that i
think they just want to walk away from
it because they really looked ridiculous
in the face of overwhelming evidence
that inflation was not transitory
uh to try to claim that it was
but i still think the methodology that
we're using today to calculate inflation
is deeply flawed and when they contrast
what's happening today to the 1970s
they never talk about the fact that the
cpi that exists today
is nothing like the one that existed
back in the night this is cost of living
versus cost of uh goods yes i mean and
basically now it's the cost of surviving
i mean by by today's methodology look it
doesn't matter if you're eating philly
mignon or dog food as long as you're
eating uh then you got nothing to
complain about right they they don't
really look at the quality even though
they claim to uh when they have
substitution or hedonics but that's a
savage the whole thing is rigged now but
if if we were measuring prices today and
we just used the same cpi that they used
back then
i think the inflation in 2021 was as bad
if not worse than any single year of the
1970s
and so what percentage would that be i
don't know probably thirteen fourteen
fifteen percent so probably fifteen but
over ten yeah i mean if you look at
import export prices
those numbers are more real and that's
about what you see because they're
they're actually taking a look at how
much are the goods that we're importing
costing what are the goods that we're
exporting it's just apples to apples and
you can actually see the prices although
anecdotally
most of the price increases that people
you know point out to me i get a lot of
emails and people show me hey this is
what i just bought and hear the exact
same thing i bought last year or six
months ago and you look at the price
increases uh they're much bigger than
six percent okay
second thing is that we now have jerome
powell as the fed reserve chairman going
to be renominated and continue good
decision bad decision or would you have
done something different if you were
president schiff
well there probably would be no fed if i
was
i would have already gotten rid of it
but um look i i predicted
on my podcast that biden would take the
coward's way out and re-nominate a pal i
mean why is it howard's way out well you
know you don't want to go out on the
limb
and put somebody else in there
who's your person because then if
anything goes wrong it's your fault
right
you just leave the guy there that's
there because hey everybody wants him
there um and then if every something
goes wrong hey it's not my fault like
he's not my guy trump appointed him and
you know the republicans wanted me to
keep him and
uh so it's it's easier for him than
going out on the limb because if
if the economy does well or powell does
a good job then he gets credit for
reappointing him uh but to go out on
left field and and go for a brainerd or
somebody else and then something goes
wrong
you know what why i mean trump kind of
had to get rid of yellen because he
spent his whole campaign bashing yellen
uh basically for doing exactly what he
then bashed powell for not doing until
powell got his mind right and started
doing exactly what trump criticized
yellen for doing
um
but look he's done a lousy job i mean if
you want to look at the fed's uh you
know
mandate of price stability we clearly
don't have it
um
but you know
i think really what the fed's job is as
far as biden is concerned is helping me
get reelected and kicking the can down
the road until the next election do you
think anyone would do something
different like what would you have done
if you were in that seat
well you know what i would do
you know i would
let the markets know that the fed is no
longer going to be setting interest
rates that the market was going to do
that and we were going to start
liquidating our holdings of u.s treasury
because they should
and of course
in so doing there would be massive
losses uh that and you know
the bill goes to the u.s taxpayer you
know as the fed unwinds its balance
sheet any losses are ious to the u.s
taxpayer because the us government has
to make the fed hole
um for that
um i also you know i would let the
government know that the fed is no
longer in the business of monetizing
government debt
and that if you want your build back
better you better figure out how you're
going to pay for it how okay this is
what i want to talk about as well is uh
they say it's cost zero dollars is that
[ __ ] of course is [ __ ] i mean
they always say that because their
assumptions are ludicrous like break it
down for me well the revenue assumptions
they're not going to get the revenue a
lot of the revenue is supposedly going
to come from extra irs agents you know
getting the rich to pay their fair share
well you know they're not going to get
much more money out of the rich
there's not that many rich people other
than you crypto guys um but and you
don't pay taxes anyway because you never
sell you're so salty you're so salty you
guys never sell so they're not getting
it you'd be one of the richest people in
the world if you bought bitcoin when you
first heard about it keep going but um
but they're not gonna get the revenue i
mean they're obviously mainly going to
target the middle class that's where the
extra irs enforcement is going but it's
hard to get blood from a stone so i
don't think they're going to get
a lot of revenue meanwhile
all these new programs are going to cost
so much more than they think i mean
first of all they act as if the programs
are going to go away in you know five
years
because they don't want to count the
spending in the out years although we
all know that these programs never go
away once they're there they're there
forever i mean we're still dealing with
temporary programs from the second world
war you know the war ended well why are
these temporary programs still in effect
right they never go away there's an old
saying it was milton friedman there's
nothing as permanent as a temporary
government program so to pretend that
these programs are going to sunset
is nonsense but also they have grossly
underestimated the cost
because the government doesn't
understand moral hazard they don't
understand what happens so
part of the build back better
is everybody gets free
um uh preschool
well
the cost of preschool is going to go way
up once the government makes it free
because now the demand for preschool
goes way up and now the spree schools
start jacking up their tuition because
they know the defense industry the
defender says oh you're gonna pay us all
this money we're gonna keep increasing
the cost of it to you because we got a
ton of money it's just like look what
government did to college tuition before
the government started subsidizing
college tuition and guaranteeing loans
college tuition was cheap
government gets involved and it cost a
fortune so
it's gonna it's they're gonna end up
spending a lot more
on preschool than they think but i think
the biggest one is going to be if it
stays in there because the senate might
get rid of it but that is the paid
family uh medical leave
because everyone's going to take that
they just assume that well only the
people that actually have a medical
emergency
are going to ask for their four-week
paid vacation
no i mean didn't they learn their lesson
from the ppp or the extended
unemployment benefits if you tell an
american that they can have a four-week
paid vacation at 90 percent of salary
every single year and all they have to
do is claim they have to take care of a
sick friend or family member you don't
think they're going to say that brother
just got sick damn they're gonna take
everything you tell me everybody that
had a emotional support animal on an
airplane actually needed that
are you peter you're ruthless you going
after the animals no it's the people
[Laughter]
no but people like people try to qualify
for these programs everyone's going to
want to take a month off every summer so
oh my god my my uncle needs my help my
kid needs my help i'm not feeling well
i'm depressed he just happens to live in
italy
everybody's going to suddenly have a
sick relative in the summer
all right so when this happens uh
what is the impact the programs cost
more than they think and then they can't
get as much revenue as they think so
what is the impact in your opinion uh if
this gets passed and implemented well
it's just more inflation you know
because the fed has to print more money
that's why the fed is talking about
printing less money that's tapering but
they're going to have to print more
money
to fund these uh deficits otherwise
interest rates go way up and what
happens if interest rates go way up well
the deficits actually get bigger because
now the government has to spend even
more interest i mean even more to pay
the interest on the debt that it already
has not to mention the new debt that's
being incurred but also when interest
rates go up it hurts the bubble economy
because now everybody has to pay higher
interest so you can't spend more money
on other things because your your
interest rates went up your adjustable
rate mortgage went up uh you know your
credit card interest rates went up uh
people can
buy less stuff on credit because car
loans are more expensive so this whole
bubble economy starts to unravel and we
go towards recession or into recession
and when that happens government tax
receipts fall more spending on
unemployment so the deficits get even
bigger so the fed has no choice if it's
going to keep everything going
but to expand the qe program print even
more money create even more inflation
and and so the price increases that
we're experiencing now
you know are just a small taste of what
we see will we see 10 inflation in the
official cpi number in the united states
in the next three years you think i
think we will unless they rigged the
numbers again i mean i wouldn't put it
past them but assuming they leave the
cpi the way it is
probably we might see 10 next year is
inflation going to get worse in the
coming year well it has to get worse and
and in fact and again when you're
talking about price increases
you're measuring the consequence of
inflation the inflation is the expansion
of the money supply and we know money
supply is going to keep expanding
they're about to raise the debt ceiling
right so we can keep uh going deeper
into debt you know i always laugh
whenever they talk about it janet yellen
you know when she testified the other
day she said six times the government's
gonna be bankrupted but the
the funny thing is she said we have to
raise the debt ceiling because it's
important that we pay our bills in full
on time well if we paid our bills in
full on time we'd have no debt right the
reason we have a debt is because we
don't pay our bills at all we borrow
money so that we don't have to pay our
bills and what janet yellen really means
is that we need to raise the debt
ceiling because we can't pay our bills
we can't pay our bills to take more on
more we have to take on more debt can i
ask a serious question and yeah i i'm
scared to ask you this because i'm going
to give you like all the ammunition in
the world
if i
am taking money from one
investor or lender to pay back
the original yes lender
well there's two ways to look at it it's
called refinancing people doing
mortgages all the time right it's also
called a ponzi scheme if they're
investors that i'm not necessarily
refinancing i'm literally just playing
like a yes it is a ponzi scheme that's
why bernie madoff said that the united
states was running the world's biggest
ponzi scheme and that what he did was
nothing compared to that and i i just
wasn't that's his defense because no but
he just mentioned it like hey come on i
mean like he wasn't saying he said
they'd do it
but this was the thing did he really say
that wasn't really his defense yes and
then the new york times wrote this piece
and they mentioned it and they said well
you know bernie madoff doesn't have any
credibility right so and i used to joke
and say wait a minute wait a minute he's
got credibility on one thing yeah
he's all about
right so if he says he's running
yes exactly that's why i used to joke we
should have made him secretary of the
treasury
the whole nature of what we were doing
you know that's pretty good yeah and you
know because but the thing is the
government janet yellen when she tells
everybody that if we don't raise the
debt ceiling we're going to default
that's an admission it's a ponzi scheme
right bernie madoff would never be dumb
enough to admit he was running a
positive scheme like that's ponzi 101.
you keep it quiet or you don't tell
everybody it's a ponzi scheme because
they're not gonna okay
all right so that's the debt let's go to
social security because one of the
things that i'm very interested in but
before you do that i wanted to i forgot
to finish answering the question as to
why the inflation is going to be worse
on a cpi
look at um producer prices okay producer
prices
2021
up more than consumer prices
so businesses were seeing their prices
costs rise
more than
what they passed on to their customers
now why was that it's because a lot of
businesses were reluctant to raise
prices they're worried about losing uh
sales to competitors and they were told
that it's all transitory okay we'll take
a hit for a few months it's transitory
we don't want to reprice everything and
then have to change the prices so
businesses kind of absorbed the rising
prices and and took a hit in their
margins
uh but i think by 2021
or 2022 rather
a lot of these businesses are gonna
throw in the towel and they're gonna say
you know what we gotta pass this on uh
it's not temporary
and i think you're gonna see businesses
much more willing to raise prices in
2022 than they were in 2021.
and is this where you see corporate
executives on their uh earnings calls
being like oh we raised prices and like
the customers liked it like it was
basically like that's basically what
people have said they've been like oh we
raised prices and the market accepted it
right they're not saying that they liked
it they're just saying they accepted our
higher prices they tolerated it
uh and therefore now they feel
emboldened to do more of it because
they've seen like hey we did a little
bit we raised three or four percent
nobody left actually in some cases
demand is even higher and so if we raise
it five or six percent from here then if
nobody leaves we can just continue to
play this game yeah i mean they're gonna
raise prices as much as they can i mean
in general businesses want to maximize
profits and so the reason you don't keep
raising prices is eventually you lose
sales
uh but if all of your competitors are
facing the same cost problems that you
have
when you raise prices other people have
to raise prices too what ultimately
happens though
as you really start to raise prices
significantly it does impact demand
because not everybody can afford the
higher prices and then what happens is
businesses end up reducing capacity so
they can achieve their profitability at
a lower scale and then prices really
start to go up because now supply is
coming down because fewer businesses are
providing these products or services
uh and and you really get the spiral but
what's driving it all is the money it's
more money being created i mean they
keep talking about the supply side
problems i was you know just getting a
kick out of powell's testimony
because did you watch was that your
super bowl were you were you sitting
there and you you had a beer and like
some steak and a pizza
i didn't have refreshments or anything
but um but pal was like well because
someone had said to him well what did
you get wrong you know now that he's
saying it's not transitory and powell
said well you know
we got one thing wrong and that was this
supply problem the supply i mean and he
said but you know in fairness nobody
could have predicted this this was crazy
it came out of left field i mean nobody
could have realized that the effect of
the pandemic would have been like supply
chain bottlenecks and i'm like what is
this guy serious i mean
so
you basically shut down
the entire economy right all these
factories close
you furlough all the workers you
literally stop making stuff
and now you're surprised that there's a
shortage of stuff you're not making it
anymore how could there not be a supply
chain problem i pointed it out on my
podcast in march of 2020 as soon as this
happened i said i don't know why people
are talking about covet as being
deflationary this is inflation on
steroids because not only are we
flooding the world with money
we're stopping the production of goods i
mean we we're having less stuff and more
money to buy it this is like you know
double inflation uh so
inflation and
you know inflation is more money in
chasing less stuff well when factories
shut down they're not producing stuff
how do you know how do new variants play
into this are they going to keep this
game going are they going to keep doing
it well i mean i mean they're looking
for excuses to con continue these
programs but the point i want to shift
let me finish making the point that
when we shut the economy down right and
people stopped working they needed to
stop spending that was the right thing
to do hey you're no longer working
you're not producing goods and services
so you got to stop consuming because
you're not producing right so we but the
idiots in washington said hey we want to
make sure that these unemployed people
keep spending
on what we're not making anything but
they gave them all this money anyway so
that they could spend even though they
weren't productive so productivity fell
but they still had cash because they got
handed free money for government and
they wouldn't just spend a lot of that
cash went into assets though not
consumers
well they went both places yeah because
some i mean in fact some of the people
that got stimulus money went right to
robin hood and bought stocks some people
went and bought crypto with it uh but
look at the the trade deficits they they
skyrocketed all-time record highs we
started buying all these goods that
people were still making in other
countries where they were still going to
work
but all of these things were very
predictable and it was a misguided
policy defended the opposite of what it
should have done we should have
contracted monetary
policy supply along with the contraction
of the economy
but we didn't want to do that we didn't
have the stomach for that and of course
we that the politicians could not have
ordered people to go home if they didn't
also say oh by the way we'll give you
the same money that you would have
earned if the politicians said hey you
gotta you can't go to work oh and by the
way you don't have any income people
would have said screw that i'm going to
work so did they have they had to do it
but it's bad because of the impact it
was horrible economic policy and the
obvious consequence
is this massive you know increase in
prices that we're seeing the supply
shortages but powell acted as if nobody
could have predicted this when it was
the most obvious thing that only an
idiot could have missed it
and and the question is if the fed is so
you know incompetent that they don't see
that when you stop production that you
don't have supply if they can't see that
what else are they missing you know what
are the other obvious massive problems
looming that the fed is clueless about
all right so when shift variant or some
other variant shows up
are they going to shut down the economy
or is that now too politically sensitive
and so they're going to basically do
everything they can not to shut it down
and they're going to use stimulus to try
to keep everything going like how do you
look at the future i don't know if
they're going to try to shut everything
down again i do know that there are
a lot of you know factions that that
like to shut down i mean i'm surprised
the teachers union hasn't come out and
said oh oh uh omnicron we can't go to
school we gotta
send my paychecks uh you know i'm doing
homeschooling again or whatever
um where they did it online but a lot of
people don't like working in fact most
people don't like working they like
getting paid so if they can get paid
without working well that's what they
choose to do and they can use uh
coronavirus as the excuse ah look who's
here peter mccormick is now in the
building yeah you know ladies and
gentlemen
yeah
so you know we were talking about
ponzi's yeah we're live we talked about
ponzi scheme before
right
sorry peter
ponzi schemes and that's a good segue
into bitcoin
although did you was that you trying to
get into reaction is that a joke
bitcoin is more of a pyramid than a
ponzi i can explain the difference if
you walk you like that picture yeah you
like that picture
oh
you got you carry that around in your
wallet
it's a bit big for my wallet
it's a bit we're digital over we don't
actually have wallets we have digital
wallets so you'd have for your digital
money for your make-believe money yeah
well hey make believe money is going
pretty well all right so i got a couple
of questions while peter gets set up
over there first thing that i i want to
understand is social security this thing
is done it's over or are they going to
figure out some way out of it and be
able to actually give people social
security after 2032 or 2013. social
security is the original government
ponzi this is even before it started
operating the national debt as a ponzi
but
uh
social security is an intergenerational
ponzi right because the the people who
got in early the people that you know
started um
paid into social security hardly any
money because initially it was a one
percent tax
a one percent of wages and the
self-employed didn't even have to pay i
mean they figured if you're smart enough
to be self-employed you can save for
yourself so if you had if you were
self-employed you weren't even required
to pay in so it was very small and the
early people that got in
uh ended up as huge winners this woman
i'm a fuller is the first person to ever
get social security she lived to a
hundred i think she only paid taxes for
like one year and then she collected for
like 50 years or whatever so she made
out like a bandit because she was the
first one in the ponzi
uh but at this point you know you have
this whole generation the baby boom
there's no chance that the baby boom is
going to get out from social security
what they put in
um it's just impossible because they
never funded it like real insurance it
wasn't like the government took the
social security contributions and set
them aside and invested them they just
spent all the money and they replaced it
with an iou from the us government of
the treasury
but it's a classic ponzi but even now
the social security system no longer
collects
as much in taxes as it's paying out in
benefits right now yeah so they're
already drawing down these phony trust
funds by running additional deficits
because the government used to be able
to borrow
from these so-called trust funds to help
fund the deficit but now the trust funds
themselves are borrowing because labor
force participation has collapsed a lot
of people have retired early
so they're not paying into social
security anymore but you have all these
people who are who are paying out and in
fact now
that the cpi is rising at a higher pace
you know they have to keep giving raises
now on social security so this thing is
is rapidly uh running for a collapse but
it's all being financed by the fed right
now
and that's the only reason that the
whole system hasn't imploded is because
we're printing the money to pay the
benefits all right have you ever met
peter mccormack in person no i think i'd
remember all those tattoos
all right how are you peter is your
biggest fan you're both named peter your
mom both are just as smart as each
other's moms because she both names you
guys peter yeah he's got a good name all
right good name that's a that's a good
comment
the common ground ends
did you play tennis this morning
no i didn't play tennis but
common ground's over now
no i just thought you came from tennis
no i'm just i'm wearing blue and white
and red it's patriotic colors but
i guess you know i'm here in florida
what do you think i'm on vacation what
do you think about this picture you're
never on vacation don't worry i know
when you got me down here no i only
vacation when i'm in the united states i
work in puerto rico oh okay
i spent 300 days in florida this year
just you know yeah i'm i'm going to do
300 in puerto rico oh perfect i'm going
to do 300 in bedford
what questions you have for peter i know
you've got a number of questions and i
feel great that i've now uh corralled
both of you into the same room staring
at each other while you also have that
picture of chef next to you
any questions i don't know i thought
you're going to like
your messages
listen
can your mind be changed
oh sure about a lot of things can my
mind be changed on bitcoin
um are you going to be i don't know i
don't know if i can get any more bearish
than i already am but i mean like is
there any argument
where you would you know if you heard of
sound enough argument would you be like
yeah you know what i might be wrong well
i just i mean i don't know there's an
argument i haven't heard yet though i
mean that's the problem i think i've
heard all the arguments what is the
thing that
if you saw it happen you'd be like okay
fine bitcoin's gonna at least be around
forget the competition with gold just
bitcoin is actually have value what is
the thing that you would look and be
like okay damn that works well you know
we're no closer to that you know than
when we first started i mean all i see
with bitcoin is people buying it
um
thinking that the price is going to go
up
and i you know if the government bought
bitcoin and put in the federal reserve
oh the balance sheet would you then say
oh you know what maybe i'm wrong well i
mean governments do stupid things i
don't expect them to do be that stupid
so i i don't but if they did it just
like they were really stupid they did it
would i change your mind i i don't think
so i mean if they just started buying
bitcoin too
i'd be surprised but uh you know i guess
that'd be great for you guys you could
sell to the government if they were dumb
enough to buy it but you know right now
i think the latest uh pump is to get
high profile people whether it's mayor
of miami or some celebrity or football
player to say oh i want to get paid in
bitcoin but they're actually getting
paid in bitcoin they're not why not well
they're not accepting bitcoin
denominated salaries they're saying hey
take my dollar salary that you were
about to pay me and convert it to
bitcoin and send it to me and then when
i get the bitcoin well i'll convert it
back to dollars so i can buy the things
that i actually need i think it's all
another pr gimmick to try to get people
to think oh see bitcoin is being used as
money uh because odell beckham wants to
get paid uh his salary in uh bitcoin
leagues don't allow them to get paid in
bitcoin well they're not i mean anybody
like like you could pay people in peach
pits i mean you could you could convert
their dollars to whatever the hell they
want you know but it's all uh publicity
stunned
um you know to try to get people
peter
what do you think about people getting
paid in bitcoin
well i get paid in bitcoin and i don't
convert at all no but you get paid by
who sponsors sponsors pay me a bitcoin
but do you negotiate the the rates in
bitcoin or is it in
what what what you're in australia the
uk uk okay so it's pound so but i use
dollar as my unit of account all right
so when you
when you have an advertiser
do you have the fixed dollar price for
ads
yeah i don't know right
so i ask them if they want to pay me in
bitcoin and right but you're not using
bitcoin as the unit of account but i
wouldn't use gold as a unit of account
if i got paid in gold
but
no you could yes you could but i
wouldn't i would still use dollars
obviously you'll say play me in gold but
here's but why not i mean because gold
was pretty stable i mean i i mean i have
no problem no no but this is this is an
important point so peter i've heard you
hold on
let's make dollars
hold on hold on this is an important
point there's three kind of properties
to money right there's store value
medium of exchange and unit of account
correct
and also let me point out because people
overlook this one but part of the
um
the store value is also a medium of
deferred payment and and that's very
important uh as a stored value people
don't talk about it it means basically
that i can
loan you money and then you can pay me
back
and the the loan when you repay me is
the same purchasing power as when i made
the loan that's part of the store value
but lending is very important to an
economy and you need to have a money
that can be utilized
as loans you know now nobody is going to
take out a bitcoin mortgage
actually they are well but you're so so
you're going to buy a house and you're
going to say i want you to loan me
10 bitcoin
and i'm going to pay you back 10 bitcoin
over 30 years no no one's doing that
okay
no one knows what the hell bitcoin is
going to be worse hold on so let peter
explain what the bitcoin mortgages are
right now
it's a different thing than what you're
talking about but they're calling it a
bitcoin market but then it's not a real
if it it's not a real bitcoin mortgage
if
you're not amortizing bitcoin i don't
know i'm just listening okay okay so i
allow sponsors to pay me in bitcoin uh
anyone who wants to pay me a bitcoin
they can but the reason i don't price my
services in bitcoin is my accounts my
accounts are done in pounds or dollars
whatever yeah actual currencies yeah so
it's it's well we can come back to that
but the reason it's done that is because
my accounts have to be reported to the
government in
uh
pounds so that's the reason it's done
but i choose to accept bitcoin and hold
it in bitcoin as part of my treasury as
i could with gold your argument there is
exactly the same there's no difference
no but bear with me with me just but
just just as an example i've just bought
a football team that team is going to
run dural accounts he's going to run a
pound account and a bitcoin account
we're going to run them side by side and
what this says to me is that we're in
this transitionary period where bitcoin
isn't a useful unit of account because
it is volatile against the pound and we
have to report our accounts in the pound
but over time the transition is
happening which is why i'm moving with
my new business to have dual accounts
with one run one in bitcoin and one in
pounds but either way i don't see this
as an argument against bitcoin it's
still used it's still the same argument
as gold now i look at when you're using
bitcoin now in a transaction
it is more of a barter transaction than
a monetary transaction whereas
when you you say you know what i will
trade you uh this advertising service
that you want for the bitcoin that you
have that i want and the bitcoin is more
a good and you're basically going back
to barter uh where you're bartering for
bitcoin but it would be the same
argument for gold no it wouldn't but i
would never price my business in gold
because gold is volatile against the
pound it's for the exactly the same
reason different levels of volatility
but this is exactly the same right well
when we were on right a gold standard
that's what everybody did right because
every currency was pegged to gold so
even if you priced in a currency you
priced in gold and in fact a lot of
contracts had gold clauses just in case
there was ever a problem that you could
you could enforce the payment in gold if
the government screwed up the courtesy
um but even today even if you weren't on
a gold standard
gold is
stable enough
uh over short and longer periods of time
that you can
price
products and
services in
gold all right
more companies right now globally will
be pricing in bitcoin than with gold no
no nobody is pricing in bitcoin no they
are they are people whose pricing and
bitcoin various people you have to
change the price every 10 minutes wait a
second every hour wait a second hold on
i don't want to talk about gold for a
second because you hold some gold not a
ton of gold uh i'm not against gold you
also own a bunch of equities right so
rather than compete bitcoin versus gold
what i want to talk about is bitcoin
specifically and i think that one of the
key things that you're talking about is
the pricing of the asset the unit of
account in bitcoin right if he says hey
uh you want to buy something from me you
want to buy a service a good whatever
it's priced in bitcoin if you're
thinking of it in terms of pounds or
dollars yes it moves right and sometimes
it's not very volatile sometimes it's
very very volatile but if instead you
actually are denominating your balance
sheet let's have a business i
denominated in bitcoin he prices
something in bitcoin when i go to buy it
i don't think about what the us dollar
value is i just think of bitcoin right
very similar yeah
very similar to the us dollar where you
i and peter and my brothers all hold
dollars the dollar has been incredibly
volatile over the last 18 months but we
don't think of it as volatile because we
don't think of an exchange price with a
dollar because the goods are priced in
dollars and our balance sheets we think
of in terms of dollars so it's actually
the same exact thing the difference is
that there's a mismatch between if your
balance sheets in dollars his balance
sheets in bitcoin that's where there's
volatility but it's really the same
thing dollar has been falling
aggressively over the last 18 months
right the dollar well uh not against
other fiat currencies it's relevant
yes i mean the purchasing power of the
dollar has declined the purchasing power
of pretty much every currency has
declined um
normally you would see that represented
in gold and i think the reason you're
not
over this time period is because you
know first the fed was saying there is
no inflation then they were saying it's
transitory now they're acknowledging
that it's not
but the market still expects the fed to
uh fight inflation successfully uh and
so that's what's keeping a lot of
pressure on gold the idea that inflation
is going to go away because the fed is
going to kill it uh but
nobody has figured out that it can't
it's impossible because if the fed were
to actually raise rates high enough to
to fight inflation
the economy would tank we'd have a
financial crisis and they would be right
back to the printing presses um the idea
that they could fight inflation with
just a half a percent rate hike you know
in 2022 is is ludicrous there's no way
you can stop inflation with those tiny
rate hikes um you know i mean if you
could do it then volcker would have done
it in 1980 wouldn't have gone up to 20
uh but that's where they went i mean you
can't tame this kind of inflation
with those little baby rate hikes
especially when you're starting from
zero right going from zero to a half a
percent what is that going to do about
six or seven percent inflation that's
probably more like you know 15 inflation
but the the bigger problem bitcoin
forgetting about unit of account media
of exchange it's the basic
premise that it's a store of value which
it 100 percent can never be
because you cannot be a store of value
unless you have value to store right and
and so are you tricking us know what you
mean by that
all right so why is gold a store of
value right well gold is a valuable
metal right that is used for all sorts
of things right
technology and jewelry a lot of things
whatever it's a metal just like copper
or nickel i mean you know you could you
know copper is a store of value too it's
just you know it's just you it's just
hard to store it because it's bulkier
but
why gold is the store of value
is because
i can use my gold today
or i can hold it in a bar
and somebody else can use it tomorrow
whether it's in five years 10 years 100
years that gold's not going anywhere
it's not gonna rust it's not gonna decay
right it's going to stay around so the
value of gold
is stored it's and like here i have gold
in my watch is it real
yes
now
i need to prove it you can melt you can
melt this down and get the gold and do
something else with that you would it'd
be stupid to melt the watch down because
it's worth more as a watch but at some
point let's say it wasn't no one gave a
damn about watches but they just needed
gold you could melt it down and the gold
is exactly the same as it was
before it went into my watch but what if
we discover
gold let me let me just finish so gold
represents
all of the uses for gold until the end
of time discounted to today because you
can use it over and over and over again
right so what you're saying here is it
has industrial use it has real use it
has real value to human beings and not
just industrial use right i mean i'm not
using it in industry while i'm wearing
it okay but you go around you know
miami go out tonight look at all the
women look at all the men and look at
how much gold they've got right they're
all wearing it
um around their necks around their
wrists right i mean on their fingers
right
people like to adorn themselves with
gold um they've been doing that for
thousands of years and i i don't think
it's gonna stop i mean outside of uh
people in india and yourself i don't
know anyone who wears gold anymore what
well as i said go out tonight and check
take a look at this anyway i get your
point so the point you're making is gold
has value because it has industrial use
has value as for in don't keep saying
industry okay but industry is one use
but you know but people use it right
okay so i've got an answer just just to
interject so give you a point is that
we're talking about uh technology
innovation here so whilst you regard
gold as money because it is money but
it's store of value and can also has
these other uses
you are not recognizing that bitcoin
also has other users but bitcoin is a
technical innovation that provides
services outside of it just being a
store of value bear with me so just as
an example right now you can send
synthetic dollars across the bitcoin
network rails anywhere in the world
instantly and for free it's out
innovated every single financial network
in the world no other financial network
what does that have to do with the value
of a single bitcoin bear with me that
allows it to do it so it has a use case
so there's a reason to own it which
gives it a price the supply and demand
on only those satoshi's to be able to
move the value around the world so well
how many satoshis do you need to own is
it or can i just have one but then i get
access to that network with just one
suggestion so what did why do i need any
more than one because it has to equate
to the uh
the exchange rate of what the bitcoin is
at that moment which also is something
that people want as a store value but
just bear with me but no but but just
bear with me but what value are they
storing what's the value what is the
inherent value of a point it's the
there's no inherent value in everything
we've all no no no yes there is no there
isn't there's there is market value for
it no no market value is price yes
everything has i'm not arguing that
bitcoin doesn't have a price it does
obviously it has a price i'm saying it
doesn't have any underlying value to
justify okay so here's so here's what
i'm saying price is based on speculation
do we all agree that commodities in
general have some value whether there's
a lot of value or lower value okay yes
what do you think is the most valuable
commodity in the world today
well i'm not sure what the most valuable
one is okay but goals of glory is a very
valuable one i'm sure that the most
valuable commodity in today's economy is
computing power
would you would you argue against that
well i don't know if you would define
computing power as a commodity but we
now hit hold on we have now hit
what i think is the biggest difference
between the way that you look at the
world and the way that we probably look
at the world which is that in a
analog economy which we've lived in for
centuries
physical commodities are by far the most
valuable when you transition into a
digital economy which right now i would
say we're probably 50 50 maybe
i'd have to look at the numbers but
we're probably 50 analog 50 digital but
over time more and more of the economy
will move online and become more virtual
et cetera so the computing power as a
commodity will become more valuable as
we continue that doesn't mean that it's
just a waste of computing power you
don't get any computing power when you
own a hold on
when you think about computing power as
a commodity
now when you look at the bitcoin network
and bitcoin as an asset right remember
bitcoiners weren't exactly uh the best
marketers when they named the network
the payment rails bitcoin and they also
named the asset bitcoin as well but you
can spend bitcoin across the bitcoin
network but when somebody says what is
bitcoin backed by if they had asked what
dollars were backed by before we came
off the gold center you would say gold
right the u.s dollar was backed by a
physical commodity in terms of gold and
bitcoin is back typically the us dollar
was gold okay it was actually defined
legally as a specific weight of gold
silver and then what happened was we had
notes federal reserve notes
that were backed by dollars which were
made of gold so the federal reserve note
wasn't a dollar that's why they actually
said we'll pay to the bearer on demand
dollars because they were paper receipts
for dollars which were actually gold
coins or solar you know so now
bitcoin and this is taking the same
mechanism bitcoin is actually backed by
the world's most valuable commodity
which is computing power that is where
it gets its value hold on because
bitcoin the network is the single
strongest computing network in the
entire world there's no computer network
in the world that is stronger than the
bitcoin network
so what so i got so i got a bitcoin can
i redeem it and get some computing power
that i can somehow use like you know in
my daily life no because because it's
not about redemption it's about actually
securing it the value hold on the value
of the dollar was not about redeeming
the gold to then go do something with
the gold the value of the dollar was
about being secured by the store value
of gold right so yes you could go redeem
it but that isn't the reason why there
was a peg the reason why there was a peg
or a backing was so that the physical
paper would actually retain the same
value
it wasn't a peg or a backing the dollar
was legally defined as a specific weight
of gold that's what so the dollar had
value because gold had value it had the
value of gold when we started bitcoin
has value because the computing power no
the computing power has nothing to do
with the bitcoin itself i don't i don't
get to utilize that computing power
because i have bitcoin you're using it
by holding bitcoin but you're using the
computing power because hold on a second
because this is very important you're
using the computing power to defend your
purchasing power what purchasing power i
just have bitcoin i only have purchasing
power if someone's willing to buy my
bitcoin from me which
is the single greatest protector of
purchasing power on the planet over
there
the purchasing power of gold is gold's
value relative to other commodities that
you can historically look back and think
or see
how much gold do i need historically to
buy wheat to buy oil to buy soybeans to
buy copper i mean gold is a real thing
all right there is nothing secure
there's nothing hold on gold is a real
thing hold on because this is an
important point because
like history is lined with the
gravestones of the people who've failed
to identify and accept techno
technological innovation and you're
siding with blockbuster and you're
siding with kodak
and and you'll put yourself on their
side investment baby the investment
graveyard is littered with people who
have fallen for ponzis and and pyramids
the latest get rich quick
bitcoin bitcoin doesn't even match the
description of a ponzi so you you're
incorrect there it doesn't no i know
it's more of a pyramid
not really yes people make money in
bitcoin because other people buy it
no it's not that's not true no it's not
it is you don't
all right when you own a bond right
nobody has to buy it from you
i buy a bond i hold it to maturity the
lender pays me back i get my interest i
buy a piece of real estate i live in it
i can rent it out nobody ever has to buy
it from me i own a stock i own a
business the business earns income it
pays me dividends
doesn't pay dividends it can do you can
yeah well oh no then you have well you
have to loan it out yeah yeah but hold
on but how are they how is he borrowing
the most important generate income
because bitcoin doesn't generate it this
is the most important part i think is
would you agree with the statement every
single financial asset in the world is
engineered to continue to go up against
the u.s dollar because the dollar will
continue to be debased because they have
no choice no it's not engineered that
way and not look there are a lot of
companies that are going to go bankrupt
i mean just because the dollar's going
down doesn't mean an asset can't go down
even faster equities there's always good
or bad within a bucket but equities will
continue to go up over long periods of
time because the dollar will be debased
real estate
yeah yeah
pretty much every real asset is going to
go up
measured against the dollar now measured
against gold something like that no i
mean can i certainly
can ask a question when you buy gold and
again i i understand that your entire
portfolio is not cold but when you buy
gold is it fair to think that what you
essentially are doing is you're hiring a
scientific
engineered metal to defend your
purchasing power i'm not hiring anybody
what i'm doing is i am storing my
purchasing power
in gold rather than in a fiat currency
okay right because gold as money is
liquidity it's a store value i'm not
using it right now as a mean of exchange
uh though it could be used that fashion
but it's not
uh but i use it to store liquidity
um
more so than
a fiat currency and if i you know i'm
gonna own a fiat currency i'm gonna be
in let's say the swiss franc over you
know other other fiat currencies because
i think it it has less problems
um but it's still not as as good as gold
um so i'm going to hold it
and i'm going to use that gold in the
future to buy things that i need
including more investment assets you
know if the price comes down even if the
price of my goal goes down if gold drops
by 10
but stocks drop by 30 or 40
i can still take advantage of that
decline by using some of my goal to buy
stocks but if we have massive inflation
where stocks might double in price
versus dollars but go down by 50 or 60
percent in gold right because in real
terms stocks went down they only went up
in nominal terms then i could use that
appreciated goal to add to my equity
when you buy bitcoin what you are doing
is you are hiring millions of people
around the world and the strongest
computer network in the world to protect
your purchasing power and in an analog
economy that may not be valuable but in
a digital economy it's the single most
valuable thing that can protect your
purchasing power because the opportunity
costs in a digital economy in a digital
economy you don't have the opportunity
to buy physical real estate you can't
use gold on the computer so first of all
you there's gold in computers number one
again again
again the reason they work of course but
but hold on
but when you look if i'm going to
operate 100 digital i'm going to operate
100 digital in a digital economy you
cannot buy the analog assets
first of all let me say something the
strongest computer network in the world
to protect your purchases first of all
when you're buying bitcoin you're not
you're not hiring somebody to protect
your purchasing power you're just buying
into a mass you know delusion and you're
just hoping that bitcoin miners the
bitcoin miners in the last 24 hours were
paid over 50 million dollars worth of
bitcoin to continue to secure the
network yeah they're going to do that as
long as they can make money mining
bitcoin which means there has to be more
fools that are willing to buy it but
you're buying in to that hysteria that
more people will keep on buying it it's
a constant pump you gotta keep getting
more and more money into into it more
people have to come in uh to maintain
the whole thing because
they still get hold on a second even if
bitcoin's price this is important even
if bitcoin's price dropped 99 percent
the 900 bitcoin that will be mined today
will still be mined if bitcoin's price
drops 99. if if bitcoins price drops 99
no one's gonna want to buy it it's not
gonna drop 99.
maybe you guys but the vast majority of
people will
will be out of bitcoin for good but let
me i want to ask you one more thing
because i don't this doesn't make any
sense you keep talking about
the digital economy the digital economy
i mean what what do you mean digital
economy i mean just because there's like
a metaverse and no not a metaverse no no
we're not talking about metaverse i'm
talking about the fact that right now if
you think of the businesses that you own
in your equity portfolio how many of
them have factories how many of them
have a large transportation
fleet how many of them actually produce
physical goods etc a lot of them okay
but well of course that's why you
haven't outperformed me but if you think
about the digital economy right is in
the digital world there are now these
businesses that are being created now
there are incumbent type digital
business so think of facebook for
example they still have physical
employees they have physical offices but
that's not where the value of that
business is derived the value of that
business is derived from what happens in
the digital world not the physical world
well no
facebook derives its value from
advertising revenue and people are
advertising real things in the physical
world that people not only people need
and not buy not always well what are
they and so take let's say for example a
media company right many of the media
companies are advertising to have
digital subscribers for their digital
content on top of that right but the the
people who are creating that content
they need to eat they need to live
somewhere they buy products i mean our
trade deficits are at all time record
highs because we're buying more actual
stuff of course we're not not all
looking in some digital fantasy world
i'm going to say digital food and live
in a digital house and drive digital
cars i mean people use wait one second
wait one second hold on i'm gonna let
peter uh chime in here in a second but
in you're a little bit older than me not
much but a little bit uh when you first
started to drive you had to do what you
would go
buy a car you'd go to the gas station
you would buy a map a physical map
look where you were going on a long road
trip and you would start to drive
and you normally would have to have a
physical either eight track or a cd rom
or whatever in order to listen to music
etc
now if you just think about getting in a
car and going on a long road you don't
buy the physical map anymore it's been
digitized you now use the digital
version of that asset you don't buy the
8-track or the cd-rom or the cassette
tape player instead what you buy is you
have digital music that you probably are
paying a subscription you don't even
actually own the song itself that's been
digitized and so there are some things
like a car that will never be digital
you will never be able to take the car
put it in some digital world and then
you and i can like fly down the highway
digitally right so yes there are still
things that will exist in the analog
world but the trend is that everything
in your life that can be digitized will
be digitized
and i would even argue that the taxi
has been digitized because now what has
occurred is the
largest taxi company in the world owns
no cars the largest hotel chain in the
world owns no hotels they have all
become asset light digital first
businesses
though the the the important part you
mentioned the cars are still there
they're still on the road agreed and
even if the drivers one day go away and
they're self you know autonomous
vehicles we're gonna digitize the
drivers no they're not they're the cars
are still there but you know what money
is like the car money ain't gonna be
digitized you're not gonna take real
money and just represent it digitally
well that's nice bitcoin
no money's already been represented
digitally no no no that's fiat you can
you can take fiat currency and represent
it digitally i'm not talking about fiat
i'm talking about real money which is a
commodity is going to be a real thing
but in the history of money
you're hoping that bitcoin can replace
fiat paper currencies
no no no no no we're not actually but
anyway just like history of money you're
obviously a gold guy you studied the
history of money all the different forms
of money during the evolution of money
did they all have uses outside of being
money did white stones and marbles when
they were used what were their use cases
what what was the use case for what like
rye stones and marbles the history of
money forms of money things that became
marble when was what you mean you talked
about marbles
little marbles that kids play with yeah
well then that's what they did they
played with them no no no history toys
historically they didn't become nothing
became money shells became mine unless
yeah but people you know what they did
with the shelves they adorned themselves
with them like cigarettes were money
right in prisons the gis used them
because because you could smoke them the
reason that cigarettes were valuable as
money was because i could wait
if i can wear my bitcoin does it have
value you can't wear your big well if i
can wear a representation no well that
no but the point i'm talking about
is that you what you seem to be missing
here is that we aren't even against gold
in this room you know there's gold and
bitcoin we're not against it we
understand that people use it people
like yourself want to store it you seem
to be missing the point that other
people just don't care about gold
they've found a new form of money and
they're going to because they think they
did they they found fool's gold
bear with it people enough people 150
million people worldwide have decided
this is the form of money that they want
and yeah bear with me they like the
trade-offs they don't care that isn't
used industrious but they like the
trade-offs that they can store it on
their phone or their wallet send
anywhere in the world instantly so
they've made that choice that they think
that's better the money hold on peter
peter sorry
why can't you accept that other people
have decided this is the form of money
they want they haven't decided it's the
form of money they decided this is what
they're gonna buy to get rich no no
people think people expect the price of
bitcoin to go way up if they didn't do
that right let's assume people assumed
that the current price of bitcoin
whatever it is fifty six thousand fifty
seven thousand whatever that's a long
way from when you heard about it let's
say that everybody accepted that this
was it this was as high as it was gonna
go right 57 000 this is the price
how many people would still be buying it
right now if they thought this was the
peak hey you know i'm happy
to have i want bitcoin as my money i
want to use it but it's 57 000 it's not
going up right this is where it is do
you think you would still have all these
people what does that mean would it
would it
would it be because then it's still not
stable because then it's subject to the
the debate okay it's gonna go up with
inflation okay it's gonna go up i'll
tell you five percent a year six percent
each year whatever i give you six
million people straight away i have it
the entire population of el salvador
because they wouldn't need to be
dollarized anymore
no the population is stable
because it's not realized it's not it
could fall i'm not saying you got a free
put i'm just saying it ain't going up
all right okay
that can only drop so yeah i want to
switch
pointless
no but i'm saying it people thought
professorship is thinking professor
schiff i have a question you can't go up
anymore
i want to change topics for a second uh
let's just say for a second put aside
the medium of exchange argument around
bitcoin so whether it's a uh currency
for a medium exchange or not whether
it's the unit of account or not who
cares uh for the purpose of this uh
conversation a store of value
whether you like it i like it we don't
like it whatever bitcoin has continued
to go up in u.s dollar terms gold yes
but that's got nothing to do with the
store value hold on hold on just means
the price has gone up hold on storing
value and no you're not starting out you
have a price going hold on hold on store
in value because that asset exists like
many other assets real estate uh
physical machinery whatever people are
willing to financialize it they're
willing to lend against it they're
willing to borrow capital to buy it all
this type of stuff
there's been a whole focus recently we
now have uh news that big banks are
starting to look at bitcoin-backed
debt
what a disaster that's going to be hold
on a second
or el salvador went ahead and said that
they're going to issue this
bitcoin-backed bond and they're going to
put 50 of the bitcoin 50 they're going
to use to build out certain things i saw
your tweet where you said it was worse
than the subprime uh debacle it will be
if they take that as collateral i
disagree hold on hold on i'm gonna give
you the floor to explain first but just
so you know
i know a lot about this and i'm warning
you don't say dumb stuff or i'm gonna
prove you wrong so i never say dumb
stuff
why do you think uh it's worse than
subprime for in all sessions why do you
think it's worse well because
you're talking about bitcoin as
collateral for a loan
and the problem with subprime mortgages
was that the real estate that was
collateralizing it could lose value okay
right and and so when the lender if the
borrower defaults
and the lender looks to the collateral
this house and now they go to sell it
well the price could be down so you're
saying just so people at home can pay
attention here so let's say a house is
uh we use these numbers a hundred
thousand dollars and in order to buy the
home uh i put down no money or five
percent put down five thousand dollars
and i brought ninety five thousand
dollars to buy the home right based on
the fact that the home is worth a
hundred thousand dollars and
historically the idea is that that house
if it's worth a hundred thousand dollars
today twenty years from now will be
worth more than a hundred thousand
dollars the problem is or if two years
or three years from now because you
might default right away you might lose
your job you know right so you buy the
house so the idea is if though the house
actually isn't worth a hundred thousand
dollars because the market had gotten
too hot and people had gotten loose with
their lending requirements now all of a
sudden i actually lend you not the
hundred thousand dollar value of the
house you're gonna buy the house for two
hundred thousand you still put down five
thousand i lend you 195 grand and you
default when i go to liquidate the house
i can't sell for 200 grand i have to
sell it for 100 grand of what the actual
value is i'm underwater on the loan
because i wasn't able to do it well yeah
i mean now you're talking about a big
decline a 50 decline in real estate
which i'm just using an extreme example
but right that's rare right the problem
with bitcoin
is a big drop let's say a 20 30 drop
isn't rare
hold on because this is really important
i i actually think i'm going to get you
to understand why bitcoin backed loans
are very unique to the point where you
may go and participate ready
in a house
uh situation if i gave you that 195 000
loan and the house declined whether it's
5 or 50
in order to liquidate it i have to sell
a house and if the market is declining
it is very very hard because it
accelerates like it did in the housing
crisis everyone was dumping houses
because there was so much uh inventory
in the market there weren't enough
buyers people in dire financial
situation and so it got worse and worse
and worse faster and faster tons of
large lenders got in a lot of trouble
very quickly we got the global financial
crisis
with bitcoin loans one of the things
that is very unique about them is if you
said to me hey i have 200 000 worth of
bitcoin you can only borrow on these
platforms up to let's say a hundred and
fifty thousand dollars against your two
hundred thousand dollars for the bitcoin
so it's an over collateralized loan now
the value or the advantage that bitcoin
has compared to your house is when the
house price starts to fall there's no
mark to market so it's hard to tell but
you can feel it in the market you can
see comps and stuff like that but you
have to sell the whole house to recoup
your cost
with bitcoin it's a highly divisible
asset it can be uh denominated up to a
hundred million satoshi's and there's a
liquid market so what these lenders will
do is they'll say give me your two
hundred thousand dollars of bitcoin i'll
give you a hundred fifty thousand dollar
loan you go do whatever you want with a
hundred fifty thousand dollars uh a loan
i'm gonna take your two hundred thousand
dollars a bitcoin if the price starts to
fall i give you a margin call i say hey
you're now at seventy percent margin you
have to cure the margin call if you
don't care yeah i understand that hold
on a second
i can sell a piece
of the bitcoin into the market so i have
to sell two hundred thousand i can sell
a thousand dollars at a time if i want
it and i can make sure that i will never
lose money on the loan because i can
always liquidate the over collateralized
uh all right so let me let me let me
stop the default let me stop you so
first of all yes
um
loaning against bitcoin is more similar
to loaning against stocks than loaning
against real estate mortgage because
mortgage loans uh you know yes real
estate it's not all identical and yes if
you have to foreclose there's a whole
process and then you got to put the
house on the market and you know you
could take a while to sell it uh and but
of course too when somebody takes out a
mortgage you know they don't mark the
house to market every day you can't get
a margin call as long as you pay your
mortgage you don't lose your house but
if you leverage your stock portfolio
they mark the stocks to market every day
and if the stocks fall by a certain
amount you have a margin call
you can't meet it they start selling
your stock they don't sell all of it
they sell what's required right the same
with bitcoin the reason i think loaning
against bitcoin is inherently riskier
than loaning against stocks and let's
say you're loaning against
non-dividend-paying stocks so the bar
the owner is not getting any income
is that i think bitcoin
is
more volatile correct than stocks so
more likely now obviously any individual
stock you know look at docusign today
down 33 overnight so if you were you had
you were on margin for that one stock
but i think brokerage firms when you
margin one individual stock that they
sometimes they they up the margin
requirements they're worried that they
could have a big move
um but i think
bitcoin is more prone
to
a
a big move okay but also here's what you
forget
let's assume
that there is a 30 40 drop in bitcoin
let's say 50 which happened last march
all right i i have an example i don't
wanna say the company but i know a
business that had billions of dollars of
bitcoin backed loans out
on march 12th or march 18th whenever it
was and bitcoin fell 50
in one day they had zero loss of capital
yeah i mean
they're very fortunate at that time but
i i would imagine that let's say bitcoin
were to drop 50
in an environment where a lot of people
uh had
bitcoin loans and i think a lot of
people who have been huddling bitcoin
are probably taking advantage of these
loans because a they don't want to sell
their bitcoin and pay tax they don't
live in puerto rico so they don't want
to sell their bitcoin and generate taxes
they also don't want to get off uh the
the gravy train they think it's going to
the moon they don't want to miss out on
all the appreciation but they want to
get out of their parents basements they
want their own place there's also
opportunity opportunity cost of there's
not many other places to go in assets
right you can't go back to dollars
because that's obviously being
depreciated gold is down but my point
but here's my point my point is that
a lot of these people are borrowing
against their bitcoin and they're going
out and buying stuff right so they don't
they don't they don't necessarily have
money to meet a margin call if they get
it because they spent it on a car they
spent it on a vacation they borrowed
against their bitcoin so let's say you
get a big drop in the price of bitcoin
50
and now the margin calls go out and the
people like i don't have any money i
spent it
okay well we got to liquidate your
bitcoin well everybody's getting
liquidated at once and where are all the
buyers all of a sudden you have this
massive liquidation into a fall mark
into a weak market maybe the exchange is
shut down maybe it's like oh you you
can't even sell it but and we have this
happening this isn't hypothetical right
we had this happen in march of last year
what you're saying it has something that
may not be
there may be way more leveraged now than
there was then there's less leverage
than uh there there used to be liquidity
yeah but there was a 50 drawdown which i
think is a fair argument to say hey if a
bunch of people are doing this and then
there's a mass liquidation right
obviously the price falls drastically my
only point is that bitcoin is the single
best collateral for the lender to take
for a loan why is that the best because
because even in your example of stocks i
have to sell the full stock so if an
applicant no you have to sell a full
share but but yeah but
that's so small money but you don't have
to sell the full
share of bitcoin in order to continue to
protect the
i mean that's that's really cause so a
share of stock might be ten dollars a
share of fifty dollars a share i mean
people when people are borrowing fifty
thousand dollars a hundred thousand
dollars i mean so at ten dollars how
many shares do i have to sell i have to
sell was it five yeah yeah there's the
amount of money
the fact that you can't break a share
down into a half a share is ridiculous
because that's such a tiny amount of
money that it doesn't matter depends on
the price of the share
no you can sell if if i buy if i margin
a thousand shares you could sell 99 999
of those shares you know if you instead
of 999 and a half i mean
all right joe you you haven't said that
much what questions you got for people i
want to know your ques your uh opinion
on stable coins
well
i mean
stable to what i mean stable to a fiat
currency because there's no stability
there so um that's exactly what i expect
but
if you're talking about stable to a
particular asset i mean obviously the
best
use case for a stable coin would be gold
right take a piece of gold why have you
not created a uh gold well they exist i
don't have to create them but um
you can have a gold coin i mean th this
is the closest thing to
what the blacksmith did originally with
gold was you had a blacksmith he had
some gold and he wrote out a piece of
paper and i owe you and people
traded that transacted with it instead
of lugging around their gold it was like
hey i got some gold over at the
blacksmith here's here's the iou why
don't you take this in exchange for
goods of services and you know you can
go get your goal whenever you want and
so uh the note circulates in as a
substitute for the money that i have uh
you could certainly do that but what
about stable coins yes yeah i'm talking
about stablecoin that's stable to the
price of gold i can have an ounce of
gold or a gram of gold but the price of
gold on this is an important point the
price of gold is not stable well that's
not gold then nothing is down hold on a
second the price of gold in us dollar
terms is down 10 percent on a real
return right but it's stable it is
stable in gold terms it's stable to
itself okay because my shoe is stable
right but the the the us dollar is not
stable in terms of the euro or the
japanese yen or the swiss franc every
currency is going to have an exchange
rate with every other currency the
purchasing power of gold has gone down
only over a short increment of time over
the last decade it's basically well over
the last 20 years look at it gone from
uh less than 300 to 1800 and over the
last 50 years over the last 100 years it
went up 500 bitcoin did that since
october 20th yeah i know bitcoin is a
speculative token what it did is
irrelevant to what gold's done a gold is
a long-term store value it's completely
relevant but i want to get back to the
stable coin
you to have a
token that is stable to a real thing
like gold or look you can you could you
could have it you know tied to oil you
can have it tied to coffee i mean let's
say i'm starbucks and i know i buy a lot
of coffee you know maybe i want to have
some of my balance
coffee it's called a digital
digital token backed by coffee so
because i know i have to buy coffee
anyway so i can have my money that are
that is tied to the purchasing power of
the good that i need so i think there's
a use case for
uh
creating
uh
digital tokens that are backed by real
tangible things that people use and
people need and then you could use like
computing power
but you you know when you have bitcoin
you don't have any of that computing
power i can't i can't use that computing
power works for you you hired it no i
can't take my bitcoin and plug it into
anything and power anything i can't i
can't do anything with bitcoin like i
can do something with gold or do
something with coffee you can you can
buy services with your bitcoin no but i
can give it to somebody else that
doesn't count as using it yes
no it's not it's exchanging it but i but
i use i use the bitcoin and when i put
it on my balance sheet i use that
computing power every single day but
that's that's no you don't yes i do
honestly this is another important point
when you put your gold you got your gold
at your house
no huh right i'm not telling you where i
got my gold all right where'd it go now
you ever seen you ever seen the meme
where the gold at uh all right so
the gold is sitting somewhere else in in
custody somewhere wherever it is whether
it's
somebody at your house and you've got
security systems there whether it's at a
bank a vault whatever you have hired a
bank a custody provider et cetera to
protect
your gold all right okay when i buy
bitcoin and you're trusting i hire
millions of people around the world to
defend to the death my purchasing power
no they're defending to the death of
your bitcoin your purchasing power can
evaporate because they're defending
nothing see i'm paying people to defend
something and you're paying people to
defend nothing that's the difference
but you're just hoping that other people
don't recognize that bitcoin is nothing
and they'll keep buying it but no i
don't need i don't need anyone to buy
bitcoin that's sure you do no i don't no
i don't because my bitcoin i see the
difference if people stop buying bitcoin
how are you going to sell yours if i
showed you
guys how many bitcoins they're not going
to stop buying gold they need gold i
showed you
not the generational shift of i think
people buying gold has gone down
drastically so you're telling me that
the the the gold jewelry industry
doesn't exist it's collapsing no it's
not the demand for gold has completely
collapsed oh it has it and i have and i
have proof i have proof ready here's my
proof
gold's nominal price not as real return
prices nominal price is down four
percent gold has collapsed no it's
demanded it is down ten percent so last
year so what that doesn't mean the
demand for gold has collapsed well the
price is pricing yeah that's how price
is determined right is based on supply
and demand
there
i will agree
that investor demand for gold has gone
down okay now people are dropping gold
investors are dropping gold no investors
are
more inclined to gravitate to risky
investments right now like bitcoin uh
because this is a massive bubble people
are getting rich speculating gold is not
about getting rich and it's about
preserving wealth i feel people are just
very very risk i feel bad right now i
feel bad i feel like you're wasting
money by hiring the custodian and hiring
the vault and hiring the bank what i'm
trying to get you to do is there are
millions of people around the world you
want me to waste money buying bitcoins
no no there are millions of people
around the world that they want you to
hire them they're begging you peter
schiff please hire me to do what take
your life and plug it into the bitcoin
network the node operators millions of
nodes around the world will go to work
for you millions of miners will start
working for you they will defend your
balance sheet for you
there's literally my balance you can
hire me this is how peter shipped this
is how peter schiff hires peter
mccormick and pomp
you oh
on your balance sheet you put clean my
bathrooms because you're gonna be broke
you put bitcoin
on your board
now because we're rich
for now yes you're rich now because
you're loaded up on the over values this
is a serious question if you had to
today if we had a hundred dollars and
you bought gold and i bought bitcoin
with it in five years on the us dollar
conversion rate which one do you think
would be higher in five years well i
mean my guess would be gold but you know
i mean i bet you a million dollars right
i know this whole time
look you don't you don't have to bet me
you're already betting you have all your
money in bitcoin
i have no money in bitcoin so no i bet
you a million dollars cold cash i'll pay
you in gold if you want
five years time i don't need to i don't
want to bet you where it's gonna be
maybe bitcoin will be higher so i don't
i don't you know i i just don't i don't
think it will but it might be but
meanwhile i don't i don't i don't i
don't see anything because i'm not i'm
not making bets with everybody so many
people want to bet me on bitcoin what
else would you give it what odds would
you give it
that bitcoin will be higher than gold
yeah
in five years time
i i don't know i'm not an odds maker i
mean it's certainly possible that it
could be higher i mean i mean could the
bubble go on
i'll be a hundred thousand dollars i'll
give you ten to one yes that's pretty
good odds
i'll i'll think about it you think about
it yeah
you know but we have to find some way to
make sure that you pay me because you
might be broke
bitcoin crashes i don't know that you'll
actually have any ability to pay me
listen that was a convenient way to get
out of the bathroom
we only have about 10 more minutes i
want john you got any more questions
yeah i'm curious what you think about
the fact that i can
get interest on my bitcoin as well as
price appreciation or depreciation um
and it's harder to do that with gold
yeah first
one thing though see if i actually had
that bet and i knew you're going to pay
me then i can actually buy bitcoin
because i'd have like a free put on it
because
if it goes down
right because but because you see value
in buying bitcoin only because you gave
me ten to one odds that it was gonna
that uh i guess
but but that that allows me to create a
situation where i can't lose except your
credit worthiness is my is my risk all
right what was your question my question
was talking about how i can earn
interest on my bitcoin as well as price
appreciation or depreciation yeah you
can earn interest on your bitcoin i
understand now because there are
people services that will pay you but
the question you have to ask is okay
how is this company generating
this money to pay me what is being done
with my bitcoin in order to generate
this income so the person who is taking
your bitcoin they either really want it
badly because they want to short it and
they need bitcoin they need your bitcoin
to sell and so they're short bitcoin and
they're willing to pay you because
that's how much they want to be short
bitcoin and and they think the price is
going down or
they're not necessarily shorting it
they're just trading the hell out of it
they're just buying and selling it a lot
and they just need your bitcoin because
they don't have it themselves
but a if they're doing that they could
always lose the bitcoin and if they lose
the bitcoin because you know then how
are you going to get yours back
uh so there's obviously got to be a lot
of risk
um
but inherently thanks to that with
dollars it's just fdic insured
um
[Music]
they lend it out on the back end and
they give me part of the yield that they
get but
in in that respect
you would think that there there's some
more productive activity going on
whether it's going into a business or
you know there's some something other
than just financing trading or short
selling
um but also if you look at the yields
that are being paid on bitcoin now
compared to the yield on a bank account
i mean what are you getting five ten
percent on bitcoin it depends yeah yeah
well obviously you know
40 basis points on a savings account
yeah i'm so to the but obviously if the
bitcoin
interest is much higher
then there must be a commensurate
increase in the risk in order to
generate that return in such a low
interest rate environment so inherently
people are taking a tremendous amount of
risk
in order to get that type of return and
the question is you know what and when
is it going to blow up
because you don't get something for
nothing and you know you you may get
this interest you may get well you may
end up losing your bitcoin and in which
case your interest is negative because
you'll end up getting you know fewer
bitcoin than than you deposited
uh but ultimately it might not matter
how many bitcoin you have if they don't
have any market value anymore because
the price crashes which won't happen all
right peter mccormick mm-hmm leadership
in this routinely
pleaded mccormick and peter schiff uh
peter can you move the photo a little
bit so we could just make sure everyone
can see it no that's my twitter photo
perfect
i don't know they're quite handsome
there like put like trying to turn it
more towards me right there and my wife
took that photo so here's what i'm
here's what i'm gonna say we have eight
minutes left before uh before we're
gonna wrap up i'm gonna get i'm gonna
give the floor to peter mccormick to ask
you anything he wants in the last eight
minutes you two can have a little
conversation then we're done
god uh okay what i would ask you is
you know you said
lots of people are holding bitcoin just
to get rich
in a scenario say protesters in belarus
protesting against lukachenko and
wanting to strike and not having the
money because they were paid by the
state
and they were receiving bitcoin
donations from around the world where
they had instant liquidity and they can
convert that into their money local
money so they can support their family
or this case in nigeria with the protest
the nsa's protest people there trying to
protest against the government and pick
bitcoin as around sending them money
how else would you do that
well again it would be much better to do
that and all the technologies here in
fact there are coins that you could use
but rather than sending a digital
currency back by nothing just send a
digital currency back by something most
likely gold so i can send somebody
gold digitally ownership of gold i can
transfer my ownership of gold to anybody
in the world
probably quicker and less expensive than
you can transfer ownership of bitcoin or
your actual bitcoin um and and and they
could do that so you agree on a
cryptocurrency as a solution
backed by gold but you agree on a
cryptocurrency as long as it's backed by
something it's not by code it can't be
backed by nothing but if it's backed by
gold it suffers from the centralization
problem that bitcoin sold so no no it it
it doesn't suffer from any problem
i mean it's an iou
no but
if you have a trusted third party that
has the gold and that digital currency
entitles you is a receipt for the
ownership of that gold
then you own the gold and then if i
transfer that ownership to somebody else
now they own that gold and they could
use that as a medium of exchange as a
store value of a unit of account it does
everything that bitcoin does without the
flaw of bitcoin and that bitcoin has no
value but my gold-backed digital
currency has all the value of gold just
like the federal reserve note had all
the value of gold when it was backed by
gold see mine does everything yours does
without the risk of centralization
but you also don't have the security of
a store of value because you have
nothing and you have a fiat the
difference is yours is fiat and mine is
real
well mine is backed by backed by nothing
it's bad
do not i don't think we're ever going to
change our mind i think we've cut over
the years everyone's going to be
rational
i think you've made a choice i'm
grounded in reality it's not like i've
made a choice you know i i'm just
looking at the rules of economics you
know i i'm not living in a fantasy that
i choose reality can would you ever
think about buying equity in businesses
that operate in the bitcoin or crypto
world
well you know i've people talk to me
about that like
let's just use the what i believe is the
largest publicly traded uh
like native company to the space which
is coinbase would you ever buy coinbase
stock i don't own it um
you know
look
there are a lot of stocks obviously to
the extent that the bitcoin bubble gets
bigger
then companies like coinbase could
potentially profit from that i don't
necessarily think coinbase is that great
a business i mean even if bitcoin
succeeds um you know there could be a
lot more competition for coinbase their
spreads can go down
uh a lot of things can go wrong the
stocks expensive i mean it's not
generally the type of stock that i like
okay um would you buy would you buy uh
last year microstrategy issued a bunch
of debt i think three separate tranches
of debt uh in these bonds now they use
it to go buy bitcoin but it's a bond
would you ever consider buying those
bonds considering they ended up being
the best performing bonds no well i mean
would i look you can always say with the
benefit of hindsight oh i could have
bought them because they they did it
right but would i buy them today no i
mean i don't want to buy bonds
um where the collateral's bitcoin i you
know i'd rather buy
the bonds of microstrategy than the
stock
um
because if bitcoin crashes and you know
at least the bond you know and micro
microstrategy could go bankrupt the
bondholders i think could still go you
know go for the equity
um but i don't i wouldn't want to buy
either i mean i don't want to i don't i
mean i don't think bryco strategy is a
business anymore it's basically it's a
it's a bitcoin etf it's a leveraged
bitcoin etf so i i would have 500
million dollars in revenue so well i but
i at this point i think it trades off of
bitcoin i think the software is an
afterthought and i don't even know like
how well they're even managing that
aspect of the business i mean they ought
to just spin the business off they ought
to just sell the software enterprise
business to another company so they
could just be just bitcoin but i think
they they just use whatever income they
generate from that business to buy more
bitcoin to buy digital sound money no
they're not buying any sound money
they're buying they're buying bitcoin
don't confuse bitcoin with sound what is
how do you define sound money
well you know what's you know do you
know where the word comes from sound
money no floor it's the sound that it
makes right when you drop it okay right
so what sound does bitcoin make when you
drop it i've got some bitcoin on here
that that uh that's that's the sound of
the phone and i can send it no no that i
i can make the same sound when you drop
your wallet
in it hold on look i
that's not the definition the definition
of sound money is that it is outside of
the system and no one can create more of
it
gold is outside of the system right and
nobody in the world can create more gold
we may discover more gold we might not
but nobody can create more gold as far
as we know today so it's outside the
system and now we can create more based
on that definition bitcoin is outside of
the system and no one can create that's
not the definition of sound money you
can't just make up a definition and then
say based on my made-up definition
bitcoin save money what is the debt but
also
i i i would say
that just because somebody can't create
more bitcoin
and i'll give you that they can't i mean
we don't know i mean maybe the miners
will somehow be able to decide that 21
million is not enough and if somehow
there's going to be more they can't all
right i'll just take your word operators
won't allow right all right we'll well
we'll see well they won't because they
own the bitcoin all right but you have
to trust that that's the case that is
the case all right
but just because there won't be more
bitcoin doesn't mean there won't be more
cryptocurrencies that pretty much have
the same properties that bitcoin has
that can't be peter's feet this argument
we need to bury now this one's no you
can't bury it because that's that that's
the elephant in the living room go and
create one tomorrow i'll show you how to
well why should i want but somewhere i
know
there's like 14 000 of them yeah no one
will care about your one how do you know
why they care about come rocket well
i mean
you were waiting you waited a whole hour
29 minutes
on your way
i'm very impressed that you held that in
your backpack for now i didn't know you
guys
that was very impressive that was great
that was a great constraint but now here
now here's what i want to say is that my
prediction for you is my this is a peter
schiff prediction is that within the
next decade you are going to have more
exposure to bitcoin and the crypto
industry
than you have not to the industry and
here's why
one
is more than 50 percent of your
portfolio will have exposure here's not
my portfolio yes i promise you here's
why
every single equity you own
is going to interface with this
technology everything none of them are
so how
that's not true come on do you hold the
s p 500 no you don't hold the s p five
yeah s p i i've heard of it yes i don't
know you don't want any of it do you oh
i don't know people as stocks in the s p
okay do you own qqq no no no no what is
your portfolio i i i own uh uh chevron i
own exxon okay they're both they're both
and exxon and chevron will both mine
bitcoin before the end of the decade
why would they mine big because it's the
single most valuable thing they can do
to monetize their energy production
there's nothing in the world that they
can make more money on than turning that
energy production into bitcoin well you
know that's why every oil and gas
organization all throughout texas
would you sell the stock if they did
that well look depends on how much money
they had to invest look
bitcoin miners are making money now some
especially i mean i a lot of bitcoin
miners live in my neighborhood there's a
bunch of them i can see how much money
they're making you know there's funny
people are like oh peter you know you do
you regret not buying bitcoin you know a
year ago no i regret not buying more
residential real estate
on my block because that's gone up
five-fold do you way more than bitcoin
no bitcoin's gone out more than you're
not in the last year when is the first
time you heard about bitcoin 20 not the
last year like bitcoin
2020. it's definitely gone up no no this
in 2021
oh 2021 yeah yeah yeah because all you
bitcoin guys are coming into my
neighborhood paying crazy prices hold on
a second but the housing prices didn't
go up five bucks
a lot you you don't live there you don't
know what what how much do the houses
cost last year
of a fourth or fifth of what they cost
this year
all right last thing is
you're not only going to have your
entire equity portfolio is going to have
exposure to this because every single
business is going to start to play in
this uh whether it's the oil and gas
companies whether it's them putting
bitcoin on the balance sheet whether
it's them interfacing with the lighting
network for payments they're all going
to participate second is that from a
real estate perspective you're gonna see
more and more of them start doing the
exact same thing across many different
cities in the world people are starting
to accept bitcoin as part of their
strategy some of that is for marketing
purposes some of that is because they
hold it on their balance sheet but it's
gonna happen lastly is that a lot of the
passive uh income that you have or yield
generation type income let's say uh
bonds or or various types of debt
they're going to start to incorporate it
as well because what you're going to see
is that calpers what is that i think
it's the largest pension fund in the
united states calpers recently just said
they're going to go more into
alternative assets they're going to
start taking on leverage what they're
going to find out is that it's going to
be much better for them to buy the exact
same fixed income that they have and
instead divert one to two percent of
every single piece of fixed income into
bitcoin put what is a asset that
continues to appreciate with that
low
volatility asset and it will still
outperform all the other costs all that
is just pie in the sky you know
assumptions that you're making well uh
nation state is issuing a billion dollar
bitcoin backed bond that's not pie in
the sky which nation state are you
talking about el salvador yeah el
salvador so that that's your example is
mass great adoption you got el salvador
been conned into doing this i mean yeah
but we've got to start with outliers
yeah yeah well you're going to start and
stop with elsa russia is a net seller of
gold paraguay is making mine illegal for
the excess hydro power yeah well look
all this is part of the hype to try to
get people to buy meanwhile bitcoins
hasn't been going up i don't know if you
bothered to check but despite all your
pumping are you talking about what's the
percentage of your since july it's of
almost 2x huh since july it's up almost
2x no but well i mean but it's still
below the the the april high eight
it was down
like i'm not talking about back then i'm
talking about now you know why isn't it
already why isn't it a hundred thousand
you know how many people have come on i
see on television all the time they
still have hundred thousand dollar price
targets for the end of the year even
today just less than a month peter peter
peterson
did you think gold was getting 5 000. it
will
i never made a hat out of it though yeah
that's because you're not as
entrepreneurial
but you got people saying it's gonna be
at a hundred thousand now are you guys
still thinking it's gonna be a hundred
thousand this year is that still your
forecast i i finally all right i think i
still hear i still got some people come
on cnbc
i think on a probability basis that
there's uh still a chance doesn't mean
that it's guaranteed to happen but i
think that there's still a very good
chance there's always a chance you're
gonna bet me on a hundred thousand by
the way you don't think it's gonna go no
yes you give me a hundred to one odds on
100 grand by the end of the year
look yeah you know
you may have a one percent chance no
would you give me a hundred to one odds
on 100 grand by the end of the year
no
because it probably there might be one
one in a hundred shot that it could you
give me uh five to one odds
on a hundred grand by the end of the
year
um
i mean i so what are you betting on some
numbers
all right before we uh finish up here
what what what do you want us to send
people where where are you talking about
gold that we could send people
well you know i don't just constantly
talk about no i know you don't talk
about bitcoin
i don't constantly talk about it either
unfortunately if anybody on is bought
bitcoin because of me i i apologize i'm
sorry they made money i know it made
sure it's really bad they made money so
well only if they sell
you don't make money if you if you don't
sell if you're just holding on all right
where do you want to send people look
but what i do most of the time is i talk
about the economy
you do understand the economy better
than most yeah yeah so we agree on the
problem yeah
and so i talk about the economy i talk
about current events i talk about
politics i talk about the financial
markets and then i talk you know about
gold i talk about bitcoin and you know
stuff like that uh so people should on a
regular basis
listen to my podcasts i'm gonna record
one probably uh tomorrow morning because
i'm i'm gonna be busy most of today but
i gotta wake up early tomorrow which
will be tough because i'm going to be
out late tonight
but uh
i'm going to record where do you want to
send people another podcast so you go to
shift radio shift radio uh shift radio
dot com as well
there's podcast now the radio is
outdated but that's the url but you
could create another one called shift
pod podcast.com and then it could really
buy that i'll sell you [ __ ]
[Laughter]
but uh but you know it's a peter schiff
show is on shiftradio.com
uh but also on my youtube channel you
can go and and check it out there
and um and if you want somebody to
manage your portfolio that's what i do
for a living i manage equity portfolios
uh at europe civic asset management
that's my puerto rico company all right
uh and you can go to uh the website is
euro pack
uh funds
no epac epacfunds.com
okay or your pacific capital europac.com
is the website how many websites you got
you're like a watch dealer you're like
which one you got a couple of a couple
different websites yeah a couple of
those we're good on the website if you
want to buy gold there's shift gold
nobody wants to do that yeah i know you
know you're well you know just in case
the demand has closed
it hasn't collapsed you know gold gold's
almost 1800 an ounce how do you figure
collapse well because he's down four
percent over the last year
whoa so what
so what goal should have been
pretty close to its high the highest
it's ever been in history and i'm almost
[ __ ] unicorn but that doesn't count
for anything i'm almost a unicorn that
doesn't count for anything
you're almost a unicorn yeah you're
you're kind of sort of close to the
all-time high and i'm kind of sort of a
unicorn my brother's almost a mermaid
like
no you're talking about this big
collapse in the price of gold
gold's eight almost eighteen hundred
dollars an ounce but isn't this when it
should have performed the best
well i yeah ironically gold is up over
ten years
gold over ten years
listen gold gold is up over 10 years on
a nominal basis three percent i
literally can go get more interest yes
at a crypto company than gold has done
in 10 years i am poor if i bought it the
reason for that is because the 10 years
prior it went from 270 to 1900 is that a
big moving goal move up is that a big
move in gold that's an enormous move up
in gold man in a short period of time
that's little boy numbers yeah well you
know in the real world that's a big move
and so
gold got overextended
uh and of course
what happened was you know the dollar
had a big rally people you know uh
became very confident in the federal
reserve and
which to me makes no sense and how
people are not losing confidence in the
fed is beyond me but apparently they
still they still trust the fed they
still think these guys know what they're
doing and so uh you know they've sold
gold because they expect the fed to do
the impossible but you know look this
the guys that are not buying gold are
the same people that were buying
subprime mortgages you know they don't
understand the problem they're oblivious
to it uh and they're wrong and you know
they're missing something that's even
more obvious than what they missed back
then and i'm confident gold is
underpriced at its current price okay
and it's going to have another big move
up and people should you know be in on
it now and don't don't just dismiss it
because it hasn't already moved up
because then what are you going to say
once it does you know then you know
you know you you live by a weak gold
price you're going to die by a strong
gold price
peter mccormick where do you want us to
send people uh yeah uh like i'm a
bitcoin guy obviously like you're a gold
guy and that's what i talk about every
day so look if you want to learn about
bitcoin then you should just follow one
of the smartest people there is one of
my uh best friends which is a spencer k
shift you can find it on
twitter twitter.com
spencer kate schiff one of the smartest
people i've ever met yeah because he's
only 19. he you know he he he's you know
he has more experience he needs he
hasn't lived long enough he's out
performing
he outperformed you over the last year
he's crushed you
um
and his bitcoin yeah i guess yeah
he's a smart dude i met him in uh where
did i meet him
well obviously he's not smart enough
yeah but you know he's smart but he's
young it's you know
when he gets older he'll he'll he'll
learn you know the error of his youth
and
you know he'll come around anyway follow
spencer k [ __ ] what's your name
that puerto rico real estate right
puerto rico
yes yes it is it is
but i i think a lot of it is crypto
related because some of the big buyers
have been uh
crypto people
so they so that so they've been the way
i'm kind of long crypto by being long uh
puerto rican real estate so uh but uh
they made you rich huh but i haven't
sold i'm not selling that's the problem
so it's like it's all about all right
ladies and gentlemen there are people
that are cashing out though they're the
smart ones i just one last shout out to
the number one bitcoin show what bitcoin
did available on all platforms the
number one bitcoin show
is is his bitcoin show better than your
bitcoin show yeah it is sure well he's
got the number one bitcoin show but you
got the number one business show no you
can have the number one bitcoin you're
number one finally after all this time
yeah he can have that but i think what
if i name only it's kind of like one
like decentralized because
i think i might have the number one
bitcoin show i think my podcast is more
popular and i think zero chance that
your podcast is more popular as it is
either it depends youtube you beat me
i'm usually kicking your ass on the
charts no yeah
yeah yeah
but check the number but if you but if
you
if you added my youtube i'd blow right
that's what you said yeah but yeah so
you've been uh you've been at the game a
long time a lot longer than me yeah all
right we gotta go
how many po how often do you podcast
ladies and gentlemen thank you so much
for watching we appreciate it please
make sure you like the video make sure
you subscribe to the channel
we will try our best to bring back peter
and peter and peter and peter more and
more often
thank you guys for coming all right
later
[Music]
you